welcome everybody thank you for coming
the professor's would be on stage our
brilliant scholars in the field to also
have a full life on Twitter and we're
here to talk about what that means their
intellectual social professional and
personal lives
this introduction was 280 characters so
there are a lot of conversations about
what academics are doing on Twitter this
is a fairly good representation of some
of the some of the more immediate losses
from fascinating gossiping about Google
in one's field having interactions with
people they have an intellectual crush
on but because Twitter has been around
for a while now in academics have been
on it for a while
we've there have been a lot of reactions
and the press about and in the scholarly
press about what whether this is good or
bad but what's the what are the purposes
is it you know that the the scholar for
instance of that New York Times op-ed
the one that with quit social media your
career may depend on it
said he's a young George done professor
in Cal Newport he wrote the idea of
purposefully introducing into my life a
service designed to fragment my
attention is as scary to me as the idea
of smoking would be to an endurance
athlete and it should be to you if
you're serious about creating things
that matter well we have some differing
opinions among our distinguished
panelists
terezi Keith is doing the work that so
many people someone you must talk about
about she's the Sheila and teressa is
Green Green
she's the inaugural Sheila and Ron mark
marchello lecture and social
entrepreneurship the author of
introduction to social entrepreneurship
a 12-step framework for building
impactful ventures and new and existing
organizations her research focuses on
developing tools to characterize and
advance social and environmental
determinants of health she also launched
the first social entrepreneurship
program in the context of public health
at Harvard she was responsible for about
launching the first venture philanthropy
organization in her home country of
Lebanon providing tailored financial and
critical management support to social
enterprises serving marginalized
populations through education and job
creation for youth and women if
Alexander Hamilton had Twitter then he
would be retweeting Joanne Freeman she
is professor of history and American
Studies and is a leading expert on early
American politics and culture the author
of the award-winning affairs of honor
national politics in the New Republic
and editor open Alexander Hamilton the
writings in the extension Hamilton her
work it's one of the writing of
Broadway's Hamilton a co-host of the
popular American history podcast
backstory which I recommend everyone
download and immediately after
extinction a comment comments are on
documentaries on PBS the History Channel
she also has an activist interest in
public minded history her most recent
book the field of blood violence and
Congress and the road to Civil War was
the New York Times notable book of 2018
and a finalist for the Lincoln prize
Michael Krause in there and Africa is an
exceptionally prolific scholar and is
also an exceptionally prolific tweeter
he is assistant professor at the School
of Management trained as a social
psychology social personality
psychologists in Berkeley where he
received his BA a psychology and
sociology and BN PhD
psychology before arriving at Yale he
was a postdoc at UC San Francisco and
then at University of Illinois his
research can be found at leading
psychology journals and has been
featured in media outlets like the top
New York Times New York magazine Wall
Street Journal NPR ABC World News
Michael is active on Twitter as he will
soon learn where he shares research news
and comments and politics and social
inequality Fiona's got a Scott Martin
next to me has been justly called a rock
star for a portraying discipline
economic literacy and concern for
enforcement in the consumer interest she
was recently named a radical by the New
Republic she deserved a teaches
economics at University School of
Management where she's been the faculty
since 1999 her area of research is
empirical industrial organization with
the focus on empirical studies of
competition in areas like pricing entry
and product differentiation her
published articles ranged widely across
industries from magazines to shipping to
pharmaceuticals to internet retailing
and are published in leading economic
journals from 2011 to 2012 professor
Scott Warren he served as Deputy
Assistant Attorney General for economics
at the Antitrust Division of the US
Department of Justice where she helped
enforce the nation's antitrust laws
yellow so when she teaches courses in
the area of competitive strategy and
many other runners and you can see a
little bit of her but the most recent
tweets here and finally Jason Stanley
notes the world was on fire but he can
laugh about this he's been taking for us
Ypres professor of philosophy at Yale
University the author of five books most
recently have fascism works the winner
of the 2007 academic
Association book prize first 2005 book
knowledge and practical interests here
it's a propaganda authoritarianism mass
incarceration free speech and other
issues for The Times Buster via
Washington Post Chronicle Higher
Education's he serves on the board of
the prison policy initiative now before
we get into our serious discussion of
Twitter and all that it can do for the
professor for professors in their in
their serious lives we know what how
things can be I thought we going so I'd
like to start by asking each of the
panelists how they started on Twitter
and and how they use it now
Fiona okay sure I joined Twitter because
Steve Barry guilted me into it he he
said people were asking where all the IO
economists on Twitter there don't seem
to be any and that was true there really
weren't so I joined and I use it really
entirely as a work platform I don't do
anything social on Twitter well
occasionally someone in my group will
say you know I got a journal article or
here's the bar cart we're having a happy
hour whatever but that's pretty
infrequent mostly I use it as a work
platform both to comment on the
economics of policy mostly antitrust
enforcement or healthcare kind of policy
choices made by the government and then
also I feel that it's a way to keep in
touch with former students who were
interested in the material in my class
and which is related to current events
and I can keep telling them about how
that class material relates to current
events so that's that's really that's
really how I use it and I find it to be
really great in that way I I think I
because of using it as a work vehicle I
don't have much of the snarky piling on
stuff that seems to happen in the rest
of Twitter and I only follow about 50
people most of whom don't tweet very
much so that I'm getting just the events
in my field
coming in
my feed Thank You Joanne I am having a
very different Twitter experience I
first got on Twitter pretty much against
my will I'm low tech slow tech and I
wasn't even on Facebook and I did I
don't know if any of you have heard of
the op-ed project but it's a great
project that's getting women and people
of color out to the world being public
commentators and writing op-eds
so I did that here at Yale and they
insisted that everyone who's in the
program have a social media presence and
in the session that we were in in the
class I said right now you're all gonna
sign up for Twitter while you're sitting
right here and you're gonna tweet
something which I did and then basically
didn't really know what to do with it I
got our sense of what it could do during
the last presidential election I think
before that I was probably tweeting out
occasional interesting historical things
I found new databases that I thought we
know colleagues would like interesting
pieces of historical evidence that I
found but during the election I guess
there was a particularly striving to
attack against the judiciary and I went
on Twitter and I even apologized I said
I know we all know this but I feel the
need to talk about checks and balances
the balance of power and why the
separation of powers is important in
this country so that you understand why
attacking the judiciary is a bad thing
and I didn't I guess I sort of assumed I
apologize because I thought a lot of my
colleagues would be looking at it but it
I was going insane with anyway I sent
that out there and I got this stream of
over huge response from the public
saying thank you for explaining that to
us and it dawned on me number one people
didn't necessarily know that and number
two what an incredible teaching tool
right in that like that something
important was communicated who knows how
many people but so I use it for a
variety of different ways I could keep
in touch with colleagues I
stay on topic you know news and also
things about my field but I feel really
aggressively that I speak to the public
about history about the government
I use a lot of documents so I'm not
screaming I actually very deliberately
you're not screaming I'm very low-key
and I try to not allow a motion to be on
there at all this morning I woke up and
I said good morning I'm gonna send out
the presidential oath of office for
people to see there you go and I didn't
say anything more than that really I
then connected things to it and said
more than that but it anyway it's it's
an incredible teaching tool that's my
main takeaway I think you told me your
second follower your first follower
whistling Manuel Miranda my my second
yeah so yeah so the one thing I did on
Twitter was I knew two people on Twitter
I knew my friend and my friend who had
told me that he was on Twitter and so
when I joined it and I made my one tweet
and then I went to find my friend and
then I thought the only other person I
know he's on here is Lynn Miranda and he
happened to make an Alexander Hamilton
joke right when I beamed in and I
responded and he was like Joanne Freeman
and then suddenly I was like oh they're
only people there's a conversation so
yeah so I first joined Twitter as a
postdoctoral research fellow and I was
and it's just graduated from public
health and I wanted to connect with the
social entrepreneurship community I was
in the University that's very siloed in
terms of discipline and the different
graduate schools don't really talk to
each other and social entrepreneurship
isn't really or at least at the time
wasn't really an academic discipline
it's people who have studied public
policy or public health or management
and they're all working in this
innovative cross-cutting area and so
that's what I was using Twitter for
mostly to find out who the key
stakeholders are what different people
were doing and to just get involved in
the conversation so I started following
institutions that support social
entrepreneurs and people out there doing
what I thought were amazing daring
things and just learning about what's
going on and how are people doing things
differently because I had a very
mainstream academic upbringing and I
just wanted to kind of break the silos
so that's really what it means to me
it's about breaking silos extending
beyond your academic discipline and
creating if not new disciplines than
just new ways of doing things talking to
the unusual suspects and hearing
different voices and opinions and I also
use it a lot to bridge my two worlds
because I come from Lebanon and I spend
a lot of time there and my grassroots
work is there for a while I was running
the Twitter and all the social media of
my organization at panache which means
lighthouse in Arabic it's a venture
philanthropy organization so I learned a
lot about comms and social media at the
time because I had to become savvy about
what works and what doesn't and when do
people see their Twitter feed and how
you should always have a photo and those
types of things that I had no idea about
because I'm trained as a number cruncher
basically and so so yeah I learned to
enjoy it and then when I created a text
book based on my course on social
entrepreneurship I realized it's a good
way to share it and hear what people
think and that's when I learned that
it's a great way to build a new
community because I started getting
tweets from people who would say oh I'm
on the second page of this book and I
know I'll use it in my course and I was
like wow that's incredible and then I
reached out to that person and we Skyped
and we became friends and we met up at a
conference and then I helped her get
into a fellowship and she helped me
think through things and so now she's
one of my closest friends and colleagues
just from a tweet so those kinds of
things I feel that you know there can be
magic that happens on Twitter so I'm not
a frequent user I mostly just create
lists like when it came to Yale I
created a Yale list that I try to check
as often as I can I think it's a great
way to connect with people so like I
guess I've been on Twitter for more than
10 years and then I was a graduate
student I started so you can imagine if
you think you have something to say
there's not necessarily people who are
interested in what you're saying
that time so so I think early on Twitter
was more of a way to curate news for me
so I was reading it understanding it if
there there weren't a lot of people in
anybody's field on Twitter early on so
so the platform kind of grew into a
place where you could like what some of
the other people here are saying like
connect to people in your field be
updated on current events you updated on
you know current studies in your field
and then sort of you know over the
course of your your career people start
listening to you
and so my use of the platform sort
starts to change to be more of like what
what am I going to say in the space
there's a lot of discourse how can you
use your science and your research and
your scholarship to inform that
discourse so it's taking on more of that
although it's still for me at least the
dad jokes as well I avoided Twitter I
was a facebook person and I had this
Facebook account that had all the
editors of the major newspapers and
magazines on it and that's where I did
my my work and shared pictures of my
kids and then the right and then I had a
Facebook post that was a private
Facebook post but the right wing somehow
screenshot it and there was like 20
articles and the right-wing press and I
got was hate stop and I started
realizing I probably shouldn't have a
page that was because of my family and
so I deleted my facebook account this
was in fall 2016 and then and I wanted a
platform that would force me never to do
anything personal because everyone
because my eight-year-old says daddy
everyone can see Twitter so so unlike
Facebook where we're actually you are
being watched because there's going to
be people like in the middle of that
firestorm I had someone contacted me
from contact me from a security agency
he said take your Facebook page down
immediately and I said why said right
now every comment and post for the last
nine years of being screenshot for
future articles about you so Twitter
gives me an opportunity to do my handi
fascist work but without revealing where
I am without revealing any personal
details of my life media that does that
so since Twitter is visible by everyone
how do you feel about interacting with
the general public do what's your
approach to that what do you feel like
you're using it as a teaching tool
generally Joanne you mentioned that and
Teressa did you know I've seen I've seen
everyone almost everyone here interact
with friends colleagues people they know
kind of personally how do you code
switch from speaking to just a small
group of people to like everyone well
there's there's two flavors of Twitter I
mean it's still just as public but I
think one of the ways in which you can
communicate the message that you send
when you use it is I'm not being as
public right so you can send something
out to the entire world or you can just
respond to one person now everyone can
look at the thing you said to that one
person but it's not being out
automatically everywhere so that's a
little bit of code switching um you know
I think it's really easy to forget and
underestimate the degree to it like your
kids people really see everything you
know they and and there have been
moments this morning this morning George
Conway Killian
and said said something about the ABC
interview yesterday with the president
in which he said he would take
information and maybe go to the FBI and
Conway said the president uh said he
might take information foreign
information and I said no it's not a
maybe which he then retreated and I
don't know what's happening right now on
Twitter what stack I know anyway so I
just replied to him but he retweeted it
and now I don't know today yeah I think
the problem was platforms like this is
you can't code-switch there is nothing
it's you have one message it goes to
everybody and you have to think very
carefully about how I spend a long time
composing my Twitter messages because
they have to be read the tone of voice
has to be exactly right read by anybody
from any background forth any language
in any mood for accurate time of day
because it's gonna be quoted back to me
one day so you I I have deleted I have
composed and not sent many Twitter
messages it's just not safe so it's I my
own you know personal conversation is
way more lively than my Twitter feed but
you can't do that
that's really not wise if you think
about what George some of the academics
have been taken down by the right for
their tweets clearly like take George
Parker Ella Mayer his tweet was all I
want wanted for all I want for Christmas
is white genocide it's clearly sarcastic
it's clearly making a joke that there's
no white genocide I mean I talked to him
after that he is like 24/7 intense
harassment you know the president of his
university denounced him for a clearly
sarcastic tweet so sarcasm doesn't you
know they will take it completely out of
context and it's totally irrelevant what
you say afterwards so you need you need
to be very clear that like I tried to be
very earnest on Twitter and as a
you also have to think not just home but
actually yeah you know I guess it's
particularly true for me as a historian
if I want to say you know if you asked
the founders this they probably would
have said that like I again that's
within the last day or two I did that
and then I went back and I said I was
gonna say they would have said and then
I said no they probably of them would
have right because they all wouldn't
have said it and somebody would come
back at me and then there'd be a
conversation so you do have to think
about every word I really have to think
about your tone I would say every day I
write and undo tweets that make perfect
sense to me and I wish I could say them
and then it's just right smart correct
because people can't do things over they
have to delete and rewrite Michael
you've written a lot about racial
inequality gaps and what do you get a
lot of do you get online harassment do
you get people who are attacking you
yes so I mean I guess the thing that
sort of motivates a lot of what I write
about on on Twitter and my tone is like
so I guess that may be the strongest
motivation is to be truthful and be
factual so I spend a lot of time just
thinking like what's the truth here and
that's what motivates what I say I think
that there's a little bit of a
difference in scale to where my my
harassments not going to rise to the
level of of other people because I just
don't happen magnitude of microphone so
it's not as it's not as intense
have you had yeah sure yeah it's it's
healthy to do that
yeah so I mean it's just something you
monitor and you're you know you're
trying to be careful but you're also
trying to be truthful and I think that's
and you're trying to be yourself in ways
that it's allowed on the platform at
least that's that's how I use it you're
you're tweeting because you want to
communicate something and sometimes it's
just to a colleague or giving out
information but sometimes it's because
you know people need to understand
checks and balances never early to teach
right you and again yeah you don't know
how many people are reading it but it's
dramatic but but again I guess I talked
about it as a teaching tool it's a
remarkably powerful teaching tool
thousands of people thousands of people
and I've been on a book tour in the fall
that whole semester and everywhere I
went were people who knew me from
Twitter commented about things I'd said
on Twitter young women who liked seeing
a woman say things in public there are
all kinds of ways in which it just
didn't dawn on me the impact of what you
do want winter that's interesting
empowering do you feel like you're using
your teaching voice your kind of
nonprofit organizing voice both your
personal voice I actually have a lot of
anxiety about tweeting I think that well
there's two there are two different ends
where I try to modify my voice one end
is when I'm being too technical and I
get feedback from people not in my field
like we have no idea what you're saying
you're talking to like ten people so I
try to explain more and use more outward
facing language the other end is when
there's something that I really care
about and a lot of people also really
care about it and it's such a
contentious divisive topic and there's a
huge social injustice and on the one
hand you want to say something and on
the other hand you're just like no
that's not what my platform is for you
know I people are already commenting on
this and I don't want to get sucked into
that and what if what I say is
misinterpreted so yeah I'm really
cautious about tweeting
especially from part of the world that
I'm from there's just so many yeah can
you say more about that I mean for
example there was one professor that I
heard about who commented on comments on
events happening in the Middle East and
got fired basically because it was he
was he was too emotional
and so people interpreted as like hate
speech even though he felt he drives a
bus right a colleague of mine from som
forward and you this article and I think
he just felt that he was talking about
an injustice and you know he felt really
passionately that this was wrong and
then it got interpreted as hate speech
and he got fired so it there's a fine
balance between speaking up and not
being heard in the most productive way
there's there's a way to communicate so
so recent without being I've been
working on trying to communicate
information without it being possible
for it to be an article in The
Washington Times or Breitbart so for
instance Jared Kushner recently had this
interview with a [ __ ] SEOs and I noticed
that he was just parroting lines from
Franklin tsa's 2009 Israel project
report so what I did was I tweeted the
Franklin says Israel project report and
a quote from it that Kushner said and
then linked it to Kushner's so then
nobody could take that hate to say look
I just he just tweeted a hundred page
document and quoted this part
well that sounds familiar so so there
are ways to communicate information
without it being a headline because some
like Salida you know the tweet that he
got fired for they couldn't fire he'd
moved from a not from a tenure track
from a tenured position to another
position but the deans have yet agreed
tenure and so he tweeted Netanyahu looks
like he's wearing teeth of Palestinian
children with and puts light at is
Palestinian so speaking about and and so
yeah so it's very important like any
like short line can be and yeah allowing
other people to say what you want to say
allowing other people to say that's a
very useful that's very that's a great
point yeah and it has a kind of academic
citation quality exactly and you can
just link to it importantly you frame it
here is someone who works for Qualcomm
saying this here is somebody who's
supposed to be enforcing the antitrust
laws to protect consumers and they're
saying this right and that neither part
of that is controversial it's factual
what their job is and it's factual what
they said but most of the people the
person who wrote the article you're
linking to is not framing it the way I'm
framing it and it's so it's so it it
makes the reader then sees it in it in a
different way and realizes oh there's a
problem here and the same thing with
saying yesterday I think I said here's
the emoluments Clause of the
Constitution here's a link to the
National Archives so you can see the
Constitution that's all I said this is
what it means right so I didn't say
anything
so you're planting the seeds right it's
like you're kind of wondering what this
is and why people are talking about it
hey here's the actual text right so we
you know there are there are
authoritarian governments there are
there's there are actual sensors around
the world then there are there's
1.some self-censor that some of you have
referred to and we have a variety of
states of tenure and did you from any of
your various institutions have you felt
pressure to tweet or not tweet or to be
to be a little bit more judicious about
what you will you say me no all right so
I'll just say I think Yale is a really
famous University and anybody who has a
job here is sufficiently good that their
own reputation is something that they
care a lot about and can do lots of
things with whether at Yale or another
place anywhere around the world so for
me it's not not about what the
university wants it's about what my
mission is which I believe is totally
consistent with University's mission but
I'm not thinking about it as a Yale
problem I'm thinking about it as a
making the world a better place problem
and allowing me to be effective in doing
that for as long as possible which means
I need to stay relevant and truthful and
direct and all those other good things
so I I don't think there's a conflict
and I think maybe if you were asked at a
different place you would get a
different answer but I think I mean
everybody here is super eminent and is
probably thinking the same way but I'll
let you all know here's a question you
know that I asked myself with every
tweet it's like how is this gonna hurt
me
right is this gonna really smack me in
the face that's equivalent to what does
it mean that I'm a Yale professor
tweeting this yeah so it's you can't
particularly at an institution like you
know you can't separate your identity
from the fact that that I've never
really thought about it in that way
because I mostly I like to use Twitter
as a connector this is just one of my
hobbies and my passions in life I love
to connect people and so when I tweet
it's mostly tweeting work that other
people have done or work that I've done
like check out this paper or oh great
job on this page
or look what this organization has just
achieved so it's nothing really that I
feel I would be held accountable for or
that I'm representing Yale or anything
like that I think that a university like
Yale gives you a platform to better and
more strongly connect people and Twitter
is one channel through which you can do
that yeah so just like one of the ways
that you can think about your
relationship to your employer on Twitter
is like well I better watch what I say
but another one is like the reach of
your scholarship is much greater to the
extent that you're engaging with it
right so you know papers that I haven't
tweeted about my mom has read them and
then papers that I have you know
thousands of people will engage in some
form with it be it like a like a like a
pull quote from it or graphs from it
right so I think it goes both ways right
you have to you think about what this
looks like as a professor at this
institution but it's also you're
communicating connecting to your field
in ways that in you know gets you
invited to talks because people heard
about your work because they saw you
write about it on Twitter and these are
people who you know again in our field a
lot of its reputation base they're gonna
be writing if we're gonna get really
career about it right they're gonna be
writing your tenure letters and the like
so as someone on tenure did it I think
it cuts both ways and it's important to
to think about that - I prefer Twitter
because on Facebook I didn't baracy a
little bit by do it so the incident that
I got involved with was a philosophy
professor gave a talk arguing that
homosexuality is a disability and I used
some potty language and describing the
talk so some party words so I have no
body work on Twitter mouths but but
generally I think my you know I'm luxury
being tenured but I've tried just to
speak my mind my whole life and it feels
gonna fire me for that ideals gonna fire
me for that so those are some of the
stickier moments of Twitter what what's
the most fun for you where do you I know
you know i Michael I know you you do
tweet about your family about sports
other other fun things is that does that
take you down a rabbit hole or is that a
good rabbit hole no I mean that all of
it's fine everything's fine what I would
say is that when I think about what I'm
like on Twitter I think about who's
watching and a lot of the people who
watch and follow and engage with me on
Twitter are our graduate students right
they're undergraduates
they're you know recent graduates of our
program our MBA program and so if I can
be my more of my full self in public it
invites more and different kinds of
people to also be themselves in academic
spaces one of the things I really care
about is having a more equitable
University I think it's a value that
Yale shares we don't always uphold that
value and so one of the barriers to it
is that you know academics kind of all
tend to look a certain way but if you
allow for more difference you
communicate that normatively you can
actually you know create changes in
norms so I think that that - so the two
months during the NBA playoffs when my
twitter feed is just warriors gifts you
know part of that is because I really
like basketball a lot but also it's part
of a part of its being a full person in
a visible space that allows other people
to see that I have a goofy example of
that trivial yet funny
so there's and it's actually an example
of things that Twitter can do that you
don't imagine so there's a bunch of
historians who but you easily Sunday
night and now
it's Saturday and I was moving that a
Sunday night but at 9 o'clock at night
this community of historians goes on
Twitter and watches I store the movie
together and live tweets our response to
what we're seeing it's actually if
you're interested in its hashtag H ATM
historians at the movies so very early
on and now the public is in there too
and it's become much bigger so very
early on in the process
I somehow mentioned that I'd never seen
national treasure so then I became the
movie we looked at and I was screaming
in outrage you know and lemon juice on
the Declaration of Independence right so
but the writers of national treasure saw
this and beamed in so then it was
historians commenting on it and the
writers commenting on it and I literally
did say lemon juice on the realize it
would seem like that make it a story so
that was just fun but that's such a
Twitter moment when suddenly you're like
wait I'm talking to the writers like and
they're listening to historians like how
interesting is that so I only use
Twitter for work but there's different
kinds of work and I think the most fun I
had was when we were running a
Kickstarter campaign with my
organization to support a bunch of
refugee women that we're trying to crowd
fund for a food truck to you know help
scale their catering company so it's a
really random pitch and so far we had
only had about a hundred high net worth
individuals that were in our closed
circle financing all these ventures and
when we did the Kickstarter campaign we
got 800 individuals from around the
world from countries that these women
had never heard of and that they would
have never dreamed that they these
people had heard of them and so Twitter
was a huge part of that because we were
really systematic about when to tweet
and who to tweet - and we got Susan
Sarandon - tweeted and you know
celebrities and random things like that
so it was so much fun and it was also
exhausting because it lasted for two
months and you worry that people get
fatigued from your campaign but we had
an awesome
time and it got funded and it was just
the most incredible experience ever
Joanne I know you've talked about
engaging with people with especially
with founding fathers fans you have a
real grab bag there is a grab bag of
people yes and so all of you I imagine
have engaged with people who I mean
there's a teaching tool for people like
your your students and people who you
know are fact-based and so forth and
then there are people who were violently
opposed to your ideas what what is it
[Music]
Jason for instance what you know what is
that like when people when you're trying
to do you engage and try to teach people
I don't engage generally with the people
who I get a lot of sort of international
tweets
I mean tweets in Portuguese because I'm
doing stuff in different countries but
that are to be portraits I mean Brazil
seems that sort of what I recognized
somewhat violent but I always engage
extremely civilly
I always just you know if I engage it's
always you know respectfully and civilly
on Twitter I mean Facebook I think was
dangerous because it gave you this
illusion of privacy and Twitter I just
try to model unfortunately I come from a
very combative profession analytic
philosophy where the only form of a
question is you're wrong because we're
all used to and we're all used to odd
he's like I had a form of college I have
a colleague here at Yale that believes
there's only one thing so you know I'm
used to strange views I'm used to myself
out of it before so so I only engage
civilly and respectfully even with you
know so I I would say that one big
decision that you make when you're on
Twitter is which people to respond to so
there are there are plenty of people who
disagree with me and write something
that I don't even understand or
they write something that's totally
ignorant and uninformed and you think I
could teach them but they're not paying
tuition so that would be a long complex
process I probably wouldn't succeed and
it would it would take a lot of time and
I don't even know who they are so the
people that I tend to respond to and try
to teach are the ones who have a name
somebody who is actually another faculty
member at another university or is a
reporter of some statue and a big burly
to write so it's not anonymous they're
in it with their reputation as well and
then and I'm doing the civil thing
explaining here's why but I think if you
try to respond to people there's a
danger that you go down into the mud pit
if you respond to people who are not
operating at that same level and so I
try to avoid responding to people sort
of will make a very provocative tweet in
response and obviously trying to get me
to engage and I feel like engagement is
itself an endorsement and I am NOT going
to endorse people who are not on the
debate in the same terms that I am get a
screenshot the provocative the trying to
get you to respond to angrily and get a
screenshot of that I've had like fake
articles done of like provocative
responses that I did you know people
provoking me and then be saying
something and they'll put a different
context that we're on it so you have to
be aware when you're on those platforms
what people try to do to get you to
respond in an uncivil way but you know
occasionally and I do exactly what you
do which is if someone insults me I'm
not gonna respond if someone is
screaming or doesn't there's a whole
category of people like that that I
would not respond to but I have had
people contact me who are angry about
something I've said aren't insulting me
aren't venting anger at me but but
clearly think differently than I do and
I clearly think well if you if you knew
this thing right we might think
differently and I have responded to
those people and I have to
confess it happened more two years ago
than it happens now but more than once
someone would say well you don't know
what you're talking about because blah
blah blah and I would say well and I
would erase all emotion from my response
right and I would say well have you read
this it's interesting that you say that
but I actually think this and this is
why and more than once I had someone who
clearly didn't agree with me politically
respond by going huh I'm gonna think
about that and it you know it's one
person but right it's like there was a
moment of communication there that you
know at least in my understanding of the
current ethos it's nice to know that you
can have that moment and again it it
really confirms the fact that the
teaching potential yes Twitter used in a
savvy kind of a way is powerful and also
you don't win an argument by showing
great emotion you win an argument by
remaining calm like when I was a little
junior faculty member someone said no
you celebrate in the end zone before you
won the game too much and talks when I
see that I'm gonna win I've seen a lot
on Twitter that especially women people
of color and other marginalized groups
are not responsible for teaching or they
should be compensated in some way for
teaching but you're all teachers so how
does that does it does it sort of does
that from the set of sense of like well
you know I'm not here for your urine and
education but it sounds like you know
of course we are yeah well teachers yeah
yeah it's the mission and if Ike if we
can reach you know the number of people
I can teach in the classroom is small
but if I can teach thousands of people
on the internet that's fantastic and and
current students follow former students
yet follow yeah so that's also it's it's
continuing and and you can see them
engaging further with ideas so yeah I
think I mean that's the main reason I
think I'm there mm-hmm I agree Michael
oh absolutely yeah with with everything
that said yeah yes
[Music]
so this is Michael Michael notorious for
its officiousness for its patriarchal
sentiment for it and many of the senior
men in my profession have decided
suddenly they're feminists because now
trying now there's this movement of I
want to be careful about but now there's
this movement gender critical feminists
who argue that transgender women aren't
really women and so suddenly there's all
these people who I remember is having
hated feminism something like I'm a
FEMINIST because I'm so yeah so this is
very academic philosophy is often had a
very vicious part of our general culture
in it and were were you know I've
tangled with with the forces he managed
it and and it you know you can't really
call it a boys club because you have
that UK group of feminists and you know
they are feminists and I respect their
views but they're they're definitely
championed by the man senior men in
philosophy and so it's been a bad it's
been a bad situation it's so intense
that you know I mean I I tweet about
trans Jeff I'm een I write about
transgender issues I've written about it
in my book because all over the world
these far-right movements neo-fascist
movements attack transgender women you
know turning boys into girls it's like
so I'm like well I'm fine for people to
have discussions about gender but how do
you negotiate this fact I think you're
asking a really interesting question
which is that does this is this a
platform to reduce the inequalities and
disparities or does it actually promote
and exacerbate existing inequalities and
disparities and I'd love to hear what
other things so in freken economics it
reduces them I mean if I can't be
interrupted on
for example I tweet so I would say
there's no boys club I don't perceive
any kind of boys club I don't perceive
any kind of issue in the economics
debate in China but I do I do think
related to your question people with
privilege of various sorts have louder
voices because they can write and and
they're not as vulnerable and Twitter
does do that but you know what that then
means to me is okay I'm a tenured
professor I teach at Yale I can guess
you'd say something right I can say
something that I feel needs to be soon I
have that privilege and I can use that
privilege so I wouldn't say it's a boys
club but I feel it's important to have a
loud female voice and you know the fact
that other women young women graduate
students high school girls have
responded that way made me think about
that in a way that I hadn't thought
about it well in philosophy I should say
there are very vocal women feminists
attacking transgender women so it's a
very bad situation and I do not weigh on
in on it because whenever I add whatever
a male weighs and I they're accused of
being a misogynist so if you if I would
say I stand up so it's a very particular
situation and you know one hundred
percent of these yeah it's but it has to
do with this privilege you know it's
kind
and I think one more quick question then
we have to wrap up please yes
so I'll go first because I'm short I
don't that's not why I'm on Twitter I'm
on Twitter to talk about antitrust and
healthcare policy to people who are
interested in that and if they're
interested in me that's fine but I'm not
trying to reach out to anybody I guess
I'll be the opposite because that's the
whole point that's the whole reason that
I'm on Twitter is to engage with well I
want to engage with people within public
health and also a public health like now
I'm in a management school and I want to
get people who so far are not interested
in social entrepreneurship or social
impact broadly speaking to be interested
in that and you have to use certain
hashtags but but yeah I think that it's
true you can be you can go down into a
vortex and get even more specific or you
can really create a snowball effect it
could go either way I I avoid I mean
I've a lot of my life has been trying to
avoid the ugliness of my field and I'm
very happy to be involved in a larger
political discourse outside of like
philosophy the gossip about my
profession
whereas for me a big part of my sense of
being a historian is public history runs
the historian should be talking to the
public
I give public lectures I have I call
those a podcast you know I do this in a
lot of ways and what I now understand is
that Twitter is another way to do that
and a powerful one might not be
recognized that way yet but I think to
me kind of like a tree so saying that's
the point of it is to not just talk to
my colleagues although I love talking to
them but it really is to reach out it's
hard to do the philosophy a
philosophical argument in 280 you're at
the critique of Pure Reason
oh well Michael do you have been mustard
on that no I'm good everyone that you
see before you I hope you'll follow
everybody everyone's immensely edifying
and entertaining and it's a treat to be
to know you all on Twitter and in some
cases to know you in person so thank you
very much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]